I did kiss the black stone. So maybe
>> you did kiss it right when you did Hajj.
>> I did the Umra.
>> Yeah, you did Omra. Okay. So So you now
guys, he admitted he went um and he
kissed the black stone like a good
>> It was from Abraham.
>> Prove it. It's from Abraham, dude.
>> What do you mean? Him and his sons put
it there.
>> Prove it. Give me some pre-Islamic arch.
>> You say that the Abrahamic religion was
there and
>> No, I don't say that. Your prophet is
and say prophet. There is no proof
Abraham was in Mecca. Give me the proof.
>> You just said it yourself.
>> I've never said Abraham.
>> Not lying. You said that Abraham.
>> NO. SHE ASIM Alhakeim said it cuz he's
stupid like you who believes Muhammad. I
didn't say it.
>> How are you going to use that and then
start saying that?
>> Because he's a Salafi and like you, he
believes your fake tradition. So does
your tradition say that Abraham
established the Cabba there? Yes. So,
did Amina and Abdullah know that
supposedly this cabba was started by
Abraham?
>> Yeah, they did.
>> So, I'm going by your sources. So, give
me some
>> pre-Islamic proof. Yeah, I'm being
honest. Give me some pre-Islamic proof.
Archaeology, not hadith, where it says
Abraham, Ishmael were in the Cabba.
>> Where where was where was where was uh
Abraham from?
>> Abraham was not in Arabia. Don't change
the subject. Give me proof that Abraham
went to Mecca with Ishmael to build the
Cabba. Pre-Islamic proof, not Hadith.
Give me some proof.
>> I'm just telling you. I'm just asking
you. Where is Where's Prophet
>> Abraham came from Ur of Kaldi and he
settled in Canaan
>> modern day. Where is he from?
>> Iraq and then what you would call
Philistine. That's why there's a
>> I'm from Philistine. I'm Palestinian.
>> What you call it? Because at that time
wasn't called Philistine.
Okay, but it was not too long ago.
>> So, you want to claim yourself to be a
descent of the Canaanites who are an
abomination to God? More power to you.
That means you're all the more proof
you're a pagan. But coming back to the
issue, don't change the subject. Can you
give me proof Abraham went to Mecca and
Ishmamail was in Mecca and built the
Kappa? Pre-Islamic evidence. I'm not
asking for your hadith that comes later.
I'm asking for evidence before Muhammad,
even before Jesus. archaeological proof.
Abraham went to Mecca and Ishmael
settled in Mecca.
>> I can try to look for some.
>> You can look for it. It's not there,
man. I'm telling you.
>> So, why do the why do the Jews put that
that black rock on their heads?
>> Go ask them. That's a file because it
contains Bible verses. What does that
got to do with Moses? What does that got
to do with Joshua? What has that got to
do with Israel? What has that got to do
with Isaac? The rabbitic Jews are just
as much pagan as you guys are. What are
you not getting? They don't follow the
Old Testament. They perverted it. That's
what I've been trying to establish to
you.
>> Do you believe that God has a symbol?
>> What symbol? I don't know what you mean.
Symbol. What symbol?
>> Do you believe there's a symbol for God?
>> What do you mean by symbol? Be specific.
I can't answer generation.
>> Like a cross. A symbol.
>> Cross. Well, that cross. That's a symbol
of what Jesus did on the cross. Yeah.
>> So, you believe that God has a symbol?
>> I don't know what you mean. Not a black
stone that you lit like a pagan? No.
>> I mean, I don't worship the black stone,
but why do you miss it? You do worship
the the cross?
>> No, I don't. You're you're full of crap.
I kissed the cross as [clears throat]
honoring Jesus who died. But now I'm
going to bury you. But be patient. I
know what you're going to say, dude. I
know what you're going to say. Tell me
why you kissed the black stone. What did
the black stone do for you?
>> The black stone is just a direction for
us to pray.
>> Oh, when I kiss the cross, it's like me
kissing a picture of my mother. I'm
kissing the cross to honor Jesus who
died on the cross. So that's my reason.
But what reason do you have to kiss the
black stone? What the hell did the black
stone do for you?
>> That's the direction we pray.
>> Why does Allah require you to kiss a
black stone?
>> You don't have to.
>> You want to bet it's sunnah. Your
prophet did it and he says you do it.
>> Not requirement.
>> A sunnah. The sunnah is not required.
>> You want to bet that if you perform
umrah or hajj that one of the
>> $100 though I'm not supposed to bet.
>> Okay. You want to bet if I quote younah
quoting Bkari in Muslim where it is one
of the rights that you must do. If there
is a large crowd then you have to just
symbolically reach out your hand and
kiss your hand. But if there's room you
have to go kiss the stone and put your
cheek on it. This is part of the rights
of pilgrimage according to your prophet.
Are you trying to deceive me?
>> No, not at all.
>> Okay. So again, why did your prophet
make you kiss a black stone? When even
Omarb said when he went to kiss it, he
goes, "I know that your stone that
neither harms nor benefits. Had I not
seen the doing doing it, I would not
have done it." Why?
>> What do you mean why? I told you to.
>> Why does your prophet make you kiss a
black stone? For what reason? When I
kiss the cross, hear me out. It's
because I'm showing honor to my Lord
Jesus. Thank you, Lord, that through the
cross you saved me. Is that why you're
kissing black stone? Because the black
stone will save you.
>> The black stone is our is we say it's
the universal
uh center of the universe.
>> Okay. What if I tell you according to
your prophet your black stone will come
on the day of judgment and will defend
you and make Allah forgive you?
>> I never heard of that.
>> So, but okay. Well, before I show you
that, what if I show you from the sound
a hadith? Your prophet said that black
stone will come to life with eyes and a
mouth and it will fight for you and
intercede for you making Allah forgive
you.
>> I know that the only person that
intercedes for me on the day of judgment
is prophet.
>> You can answer the question. See, this
is why we're getting frustrated. I'm
gonna ask it a third time. I'm gonna see
I like threes. Okay. What if I show you
from the soundah hadith
that your prophet said the black stone
will have eyes and a mouth and it will
intercede and fight for you and make
Allah forgive you? What are you going to
say about your prophet? You going to say
he's a pagan?
>> No.
>> Why not? Because the pagans said the
same thing. In your Quran, the pagans
told your prophet the reason why we
worship the stones and the idols is so
that they can bring bring us near to
Allah. That's in chapter 39:3 of your
Quran. Read it. 39:3. It says that the
only reason why we worship them is so
that they can bring us near to Allah.
Because by honoring them, we're hoping
they will intercede and bring us closer
to Allah. That's exactly what your
prophet said the black stone will do.
>> You said, "You're no better than the
pagans."
>> 393.
>> Yes. Read it. Unquestionably for Allah
is the pure religion and those who take
protectors besides him say we only
worship them that they may bring us near
to Allah in position indeed Allah
>> they worship them
>> what's that
>> why did the pagans worship the statues
and the stones
>> we only worship them that they may bring
us near to Allah in position
>> but guess But how did they worship the
stones and the idol? They would kiss it.
They would put their face on it. And one
of them was the black stone. So Muhammad
condemns them for doing that. But then
he has you pagans doing the same thing.
>> No, because the the the things the idol,
whatever you want to call them, were
inside the Kaa.
>> Not all of them. They were not. No.
>> Well, I mean, says that the statue of
Hubal was outside on the top.
>> There are some outside, but for the most
part, they're all inside. Can you forget
trying to say because you just admit
even outside. Do you understand why they
did it? Let's try the logic again.
>> Yeah. So Allah could be.
>> So what's the difference between those
pagans and you pagans when you're doing
the same thing?
>> Because we're not worshiping the stone.
We're worshiping
>> Yes, you are. When you kiss it and you
put your cheek on it, that's exactly
what the pagans did to their idols and
stones for the same reason. Because your
prophet says when you kiss it and you
put your cheek on it, it will come to
life and defend you before Allah. Oh
Allah, he used to lick me and smooch me,
so forgive him.
You're no different than the pagans,
dude.
>> I guess.
>> Here, let me show it to you. Here it is.
So, you're a pagan. You don't worship
one god. You're a pagan. You have many
gods. Here's one. Here's the link right
here. that. Well, can you click on it so
you don't think I'm lying here?
>> Not my Lord.
>> Well, that makes it even worse. So,
you're smooching and smothering a stone
that's not your Lord. Don't you
understand? You're burying yourself even
more. So, you're going to smooch a black
stone that's not your Lord. And you
still don't You're a pagan
>> because I kissed a rock. I worship it
now.
>> Okay, let's try this again.
The pagans would kiss the stones and the
idols and they would actually touch the
stones and idols because they believe
these idols and stones representing
their gods would intercede for them.
Your prophet said that black stone that
you touch and kiss it will come to life
intercede for you. So it's no different
from the pagans. What are you not
getting?
>> I see where you're coming from. But what
you're not understanding is them kissing
those stones, those those idols, they
believe that those were gods.
>> Sure, that's okay. But they didn't think
they were Allah. They thought they would
bring them closer to Allah. So you don't
call it a god, but you're doing the same
thing. I'm going to lick this black
stone cuz it's going to bring me closer
to Allah. That's
>> we we do believe as Muslims that
everything on the day of judgment will
come to life. Trees.
>> No, that's okay. I'm fine. Here it is.
It was narrated that bin jub you want to
read the hadith
>> mountains everything will be alive.
>> You want me to read the hadith? Here it
is. It was narrated that say bin jub
said I heard Ib Abbas Muhammad's cousin
the messenger this stone will be brought
on the day of resurrection and will be
given two eyes with which
[clears throat]
it sees and a tongue with which to speak
and will bear witness for those who
touch it in sincerity. So it's going to
be your intercessor
and it's great Hassan Hassan. Goodb
Maja number 2944. I gave you the link.
So and you're trying to convince us you
guys are not pagans. Okay, I'm
convinced.
>> I mean we're we're we're kissing. Okay,
we kiss the rock. How does that make us
pagan? We don't worship the rock
>> because the pagans did the same thing.
They would kiss stones thinking that
kissing these stones would bring them
closer to Allah for them
>> those stones. There's a difference. And
when you kiss a stone and you touch it
hoping that it will save you, then
you're doing the same thing even though
you don't like to use the word.
>> Even Omar, didn't you say this?
>> Yes.
>> Doesn't do anything. We already know
this. This
>> Okay, but you let me repeat again. You
may not use the word worship. You can
deny all you want. It's not worship.
What you say, you contradict by your
deeds. You may say, "I'm not worshiping
it." But by your action when you kiss it
and touch it hoping it will take your
sin and defend you. That is worship
because you're depending on it to
intercede for you. That's what a god is.
Someone who comes to help you and defend
you. That's what an is. I don't know if
you know that.
>> Believe that Muhammad intercedes for us
on the day of judgment. We don't
>> I just gave you the hadith. The black
stone will also intercede for you. Yeah.
I just gave it to you. You just said
that a god intercedes.
[sighs]
>> That's what you just said.
>> Let me now tell you that Muhammad is
your other god. That's the other pagan
god that you worship.
>> We we don't worship Muhammad peace.
>> You do by your deeds. Don't change the
sound. I'm going to show you that you
worship Muhammad. You're Muhammad. And
I'll prove it. Your god is Allah.
Muhammad, the black stone, the Quran,
they're all your gods. I'll prove it.
But before we get to Muhammad as your
god, do you are you okay with a stone
coming to life and interceding for you
and defending you, which is what an Elah
does? Why do you think they worship them
as gods? Cuz they are our protectors and
defenders. So you may not call it a god.
You may not call it worship, but when
you're kissing it to honor it and
touching it to revere it and trusting
that it will defend you, that's what an
idol is. and Ela a goddess.